violence is a CBS News law enforcement
analyst and CEO of Vilas Group
International Paul good morning good
morning Charlie where are we in terms of
the search for motive we are a lot
closer than we're in the beginning of
the week not to be cryptic but we still
have a long road to go specifically well
we have learned a considerable amount
about the behavioural characteristics of
the shooter patek has through interviews
we're learning with respect to his
mental state were confirming that was
mental length the illness and mental
anguish were understanding more and more
about where he was placing his mindset
with regarding to the acquisition of
weapons the positioning of his
girlfriend's so a lot is actually coming
to play right now where the profile is
being built neatly and they're building
further into that violence I assume it's
a girlfriend but others as well yes no
question their family members co-workers
and now they're going to start to go
back to Florida we'll be talking about
before where he lived for a long period
of time and they're gonna get into the
mental state there and looking for the
impetus something that created a change
in him that sparked this movement in
this planning what do you make about the
girlfriend you were with us on Monday as
this story was breaking where we really
knew nothing but in the beginning when
we first heard her name she said she
didn't know anything she was very
surprised you know she thought when he
sent the money to her maybe he was
breaking up now she's saying well there
were some mental mental health issues
that I was concerned about what do you
think about her you know what Gail I
think that she's really interesting I
think she's giving a little pieces of
information at a time I think she's
really afraid to tell the truth she's
not being for threat because she's
afraid she may get into trouble she
lawyered up immediately which is
assigned to me or to automatically but
the first part here is the fact that
she's giving pieces of mental illness
now that to her were blatant and overt
but she never said that before what she
never said that before so she's giving
investigators a little pieces at a time
I what I truly believe is that and if I
was interviewing her I think where I
would be going with this sort of like
the parent and the child she's given
she's given mom a little bit at a time
because she thinks she's not going to
get into trouble that way eventually
she's gonna have to come out and really
explain how much he actually knew Gail
you simply can't a choir of 47 wrong
about 47 weapons most of which long guns
store them in a house that you live in
and say I didn't
no and how much this is the one with a
lot of material wealth planes apartments
how much is the money trails going to be
useful intermediate in determining a
motive considerable announced that is
really the most poignant point of this
too is we talked to our viewers about
the process and how long this is going
to take remember if we were mark
aborting this you've got ATF that's
tracking all of those firearms and then
you've got the financial component the
FBI is clearly doing on the forensic
accounting side modeling everywhere he
spent money where he wired money who did
he wire to who are they who were they
affiliated with and that in itself the
process of interviewing each person then
once they interview them more people
will come out of this interview so that
is going to be key in deciding really
what the impetus was and who inspired
him and authorities certainly know more
than they're telling us at this time
there's no question about that yeah
that's a safe bet
thank you very much yes ma'am my
pleasure